breaking news tonight a shooting at an
elementary school in Texas leaves 18
children second third and fourth graders
dead as well as two adults as well as
the suspect it is the deadliest school
shooting in Texas history and the
deadliest since the Sandy Hook shooting
almost a decade ago
a school in the small town of Uvalde
Texas this morning at about 10 30. that
town is about 70 miles just north of the
U.S Mexico border 80 miles west of San
Antonio we've also learned that the 18
year old shooter is dead apparently
killed by police responding to that
shooting now the video you're looking at
shows parents at a Civic Center in the
town of Uvalde where they were given
information about their children
President Biden addressing the nation
just a short while ago and his remarks
very personal
to lose a child
is like having a piece of your soul
ripped away
there's a hollowness in your chest you
feel like you're being sucked into it
you're never going to be able to get out
suffocating
the flag at the White House was lowered
to half staff after the school shooting
in Texas and President Biden has ordered
flags on all federal buildings
Nationwide to be lowered as well
Las Vegas mayor Carolyn Goodman
responding and tweeting we can't imagine
the pain the families in Uvalde Texas
are experiencing the loss of these
innocent lives is beyond comprehension
we are horrified and may their souls
rest in peace and from Governor sisilak
he says quote our hearts are broken
again Kathy and I are sending our love
and our prayers to the Uvalde community
in Texas in the aftermath of this
horrific shooting CCSD also released in
a statement this evening extending
supporter reads and park quote this
unfathomable event paxed students
Educators staff and administrators
across the country who care deeply about
the health and well-being of every
student safety remains a top priority
for all school districts including here
in southern Nevada and we will continue
to follow this story through the evening
bring you updates as they do become
available